tu cherches j'ai la dalle je voulais
faire une omelette avec une brosse à
dents
[Musique]
ça va durer combien de temps ce truc là
ils peuvent pas dormir sur palop l'autre
jean baptiste son grand-père il faut
toujours savoir où il est il et autorise
et comment ça va roland on se connaît
pas ce que l on se connaît roland bacou
makoun malgré mon chéri on avait un
petit problème conduite en état
d'ivresse de 28 ans en avait encore pour
longtemps
pourquoi vous attend pour l'apéro même à
manger ma finale et c'est quoi le projet
voulait gâcher ma vie non aujourd'hui
c'est pas un match comme les autres
c'est une finale pour certains d'entre
vous la vie peut changer d'un seul coup
pim pam sert à rien toutes façons je
serai jamais claveciniste et pas il faut
y croire c'est ça le sport et ça c'est
une voiture de sport fia
je sais plus comment ça marche conduite
voilà quoi tu sais conduire dans les
camps conduite accompagnée je
raccompagnais
m
or la fage ça veut dire
tu te rends compte des risques que tu as
fait prendre à ton grand père un coup tu
parles tu en a rien à [ __ ] de lui
tu l'as toujours détesté
une famille c'est comme une équipe sur
votre tout le monde gagne faut pas jouer
perso
il a compris c'est un petit
[Musique]
il m'a pas laissé sur le banc lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]